does the NFL turn into a global game 30
years down the road they're certainly
gonna try I think it was Robert Kraft
who said we've already saturated the
market everyone in America is watching
the Super Bowl now we have these big
markets overseas they're gonna try
everything they can you know I think the
most recent push has not succeeded
everyone thinks it travels too much for
London you know we're talking about
technology who knows maybe that changes
a little bit in 30 years I would be
surprised if they hadn't expanded out of
the country what would you think it's a
player having to go to Berlin for a game
with a turnaround to go to wherever it
might be maybe I the west coast of the
United States as a player can you fathom
that type of travel I'm all for it you
know I think that you know haven't
haven't teamed what it would definitely
be a team in London that we kind of see
that coming down the pipe and you
started looking at travel I'm what's the
difference between flying from New York
City to play the seattle seahawks or
flying from New York and going to London
I mean really the travel is not that
much I definitely was a player I
wouldn't mind living in a you know for
for an off season four season I wouldn't
mind living in London or living in
Berlin now when you start talking about
you know player safety and recovery
that's where hyperbaric chambers inside
of the plane and say hey you know what
when my players get into the plane they
can get into this hyperbaric chamber
they can recover on to the next I mean
you never know I mean think about it
we're talking about absolutely Jetsons I
mean anything yeah yeah yeah it's like
him back to the future to all that stuff
came true why can't we and I way I want
to get on that plane all right furniture
pearl off and tony richardson i'm ryan
insulting thanks for being with us